bonjour
bonsoir merci de cette
présentation je vous rassure je descends
pas d'un château obscur des Carpates je
m'appelle bien jeanel tissau je suis sur
ce porphy qui ressemble à ces pierres
qu'on trouve dans les basiliques majeurs
romaines et ce que j'aimerais faire avec
avec vous aujourd'hui c'est de vous
envoyer en l'air pour une odyssée
sanguine odyssée sanguine qui va se
passer en plusieurs
étapes 14 secondes 14 secondes de chute
du Niagara pourquoi est-ce que je vous
ai mis cette petite vidéo mesdames
messieurs et bien tout simplement ça
correspond à la quantité de sang qui est
transfusé chaque année selon les données
de l'OMS de 2011 c'est 38 millions de
litres de sang qui sont échangés entre
des donneurs et des receveurs ça
correspond à une somme de 1.25 lit par
seconde de sang qui passe d'un individu
à un
autre c'est absolument incroyable cette
quantité sachant que vous et moi avons 5
L de sang quel que soit à peu près votre
la quantité chez un adulte est de 5 L de
sang par ces 5 L de sang et bien vous
avez une quantité d'à peu près de la
moitié qui est faite d'éléments
cellulaires le plus important ce sont
les globules rouges et les globules
rouges vous en avez 20 milliards alors
est-ce que vous pouvez imaginer ce que
c'est qu'un milliard quand vous avez
2000 francs de dette vous voyez à peu
près ce que c'est quand vous avez 20
milliards de dettes c'est plutôt votre
banquier qui a des soucis ou vos
autorités sur ces 20 milliards de
globules roues vous devez en renouveler
tous les jours un 120e c'està dire qu'il
y a un énorme travail tous les jours qui
est fait par votre moile pour fabriquer
des globules rouge mais évidemment il
faut aussi éliminer les anciens globules
rouges et je reviendrai sur cette notion
fondamentale qui est l'élimination des
cellules qui ont fait leur activité au
fil de ces 120 jours qui est leur
vie alors pour reprendre cette odyssée
on a pas mal de chemins à parcourir ce
chemin à parcourir va se faire à travers
des petits vaisseaux artériels des
petits vaisseaux veineux qu'on appelle
capillair et finalement votre globule
rouge il est capable de se balader sur
km alors vous voyez quand vous prenez le
m2 ou quand vous prenez le M1 restant
assis en faisant vos quelques kilomètres
au sein de la ville de Lausanne vos
globules rouges eux vont profiter
d'avoir un circuit qui est un tout petit
peu plus intéressant et non taxé ça
j'étais Fortin comment j'ai pu mettre
cet animal dans un diaporama alors qu'on
va discuter de sang et des valeurs des
produits sanguins et bien tout
simplement personne ne peut toucher main
nu cet animal parce qu'il est beaucoup
trop toxique et la nature a fait quelque
chose d'absolument splendide elle a rei
à inventer une cellule qu'on appelle le
globule rouge en fait il est réellement
rouge c'est pas une vue de l'esprit
c'est un globule rouge et ce globule
rouge c'est une enveloppe qui permet
d'inclure à son intérieur trois toxiques
majeurs l'hémoglobine si je vous injecte
de l'hémoglobine je vous tue si je vous
injecte de l'hémoglobine à l'intérieur
de la membrane globulaire à l'intérieur
de l'érrythrocyte et bien tout va bien
se passer le deuxième toxique paradoxal
c'est l'oxygène on supporte pas
l'oxygène bon peut-être nos mères savent
bien quand on leur pompelire toute la
relation qui est avec elle mais
l'oxygène est un toxique absolument
horrible dès le moment où vous avez trop
d'oxygène vous allez avoir des lésions
importantes et le dernier toxique c'est
le fer le fer doit être associé à
différentes protéines ou du sucre pour
pouvoir circuler à l'intérieur de ce
globues rougge ou être présent à
l'intérieur de nos cellules pour
différentes fonctions la nature a réussi
à mettre ces trois toxiques les
envelopper et c'est ce qu'on appelle le
globule rouge maintenant on va continuer
pendant quelques instants à la place de
discuter des éléments cellulaires je
vais vous parler un tout petit peu du
sang et de ses origines le sang non
masculin bon qui arrive de deux origines
latines qui ont été utilisées la
première c'est sangwiis sangwiis dont va
dériver énormément de mots que vous
connaissez y compris exenle sensu mais
c'est le sang à l'intérieur du corps
c'est le sang qui vous permet de vivre
c'est le sang qui vous permet d'échanger
l'oxygène avec vos poumons et vos tissus
l'autre mot qui a été utilisé pendant
longtemps est un mot tout à fait
différent qui est CRUD d'or c'est le
sang répandu et immédiatement avec CRUD
d'or et ce sang rép endu on va être
confronté une autre notion qui est la
cruauté qui est cruelle qui est la
notion portée dans le mot de sang qui
est cette notion de mort qui est
omniprésente systématiquement d'ailleurs
quand on va traiter des malades avec des
maladies du sang ou des maladies qui
saigne on est toujours dans cet espace
entre la vie et l'autre confin qui
potentiellement est la mort ces mots
sont importants dans la langue française
dans différentes langues évidemment
j'aimerais juste illustrer mon propos
avec deux pression garder son sang froid
avoir le sang chaud donc le sang peut
tout bon sang ne peut motir et puis se
faire du mauvais sang donc le sang
peut-être chaud peut-être froid
peut-être bon peut-être mauvais som tout
il a mis à toutes les sauces de notre
langage mais au-delà des sauces de notre
langage il y a des points qui sont
importants à se rappeler dans l'histoire
un monsieur a découvert la circulation
sanguine pour n'importe qui entre nous
on sait qu'il par passe par le cœur va
aller dans les artères revenir par les
veines mais c'est monsieur harvy qui a
démontré pour la première fois que
réellement il y avait une circulation
puis c'était pas simplement une pression
à l'intérieur des vaisseaux qui pouvait
faire le sang dans notre corps et puis
le grand miracle aussi c'est que le sang
va pouvoir passer dans tous les organes
du cerveau à vos orteils à vos doigts à
votre thorax bien entendu et ça sera
discuté dans d'autres espaces
aujourd'hui avec le cœur qui est un
organe fondamental ce sang contient
différents éléments les éléments figurés
du sang ce sont les cellules ce sont les
globules rouges les globules blancs les
plaquettes mais il y a toutes sortes de
protéines et ces protéines je vais vous
donner deux exemples principaux c'est la
coagulation la capacité de faire un
caillot arrêtter de saigner où ce sont
les anticorps qui vont vous permettre de
vous débarrasser contre différents
pathogènes virus bactéries et cetera ces
protéines sont extrêmement importantes
ont été bien caractérisé ces dernières
années et là de nouveau le miracle que
je peux vous présenter c'est que les
globules rouges y compris avec les
colorations de laboratoire reste rouge
par contre les globules blancs c'est ces
petites taches bleues c'est t étrange de
parler de globules blancs qui sont bleus
et j'avais un maître d'hématologie qui
était daltonien il décrivait le bleu le
rouge systématiquement et c'était
parfois un tout petit peu cocasse comme
il arrivaient àeémerveillé avec les
variations colorées sachant qu'il avait
quel problème de de reconnaissance nos
techniques qui sont à disposition de
laboratoires sont absolument
éblouissants on est capable de séparer
toutes sortes de cellules toutes sortes
de population à l'intérieur du sang on
est capable de les isoler de les mettre
dans un tube de voir quels sont les
protéines qui sont synthétisées quels
sont les gènes qui sont exprimés donc on
est capable maintenant d'aller à la
rencontre de chacune de nos cellules on
va vers l'infiniment petit et puis aussi
un point sur lequel j'aimerais insister
naturellement avec le métier qui est le
mien qui est celui de la transfusion
sanguine c'est de vous rappeler qu'il y
a autant de différence entre la surface
de deux globules rouges en terme de
sucre de protéin qu'on appelle groupe
sanguin contre deux visages en deux
visages il y a un polymorphisme
extraordinaire qui fait la beauté du
monde la beauté de la relation mais
c'est la même chose sur les globules
rouge à travers ces groupes sanguins
image étrange est-ce que vous savez ce
que
c'est ça rien à voir avec mon
topo et bien c'est le Gange et pourquoi
je veux insister 2 minutes sur le Gange
et bien c'est pour vous montrer la
beauté de ce fleuve avec une poésie que
je trouve extrêmement impressionnante
avec ses fleurs ses bateaux qui vont
circuler mais surtout vous rappelez à
travers cette image que le sang liquide
sacré au même titre que ce fleuve qui
porte autant de valeur et bien va
véhiculer tous vos déchets tous vos
cadavres cellulaires son dans votre sang
au point même qu'avec les technologies
dont on dispose on peut regarder
différents biomarqueurs trouver des
maladies le cancer bien sûr il y a
toutes sortes d'études qui nous ont
montré donc gardez bien dans votre tête
que le sang qui a été sacralisé pour
cause dans notre éducation chrétienne
porte en lui-même tous les déchets de
notre corps et je crois qu'on doit
revaloriser les déchets je veux pas dire
que je veux vous donner un cours
d'écologie mais l'organisme sait faire
ça il sait réutiliser les vieilles
protéines il sait réutiliser les
anciennes choses et les recycler de
manière optimale mais pensez bien que le
sang a un rôle fondamental pour amener
les déchets au niveau du foie du rein et
cetera en hématologiste on est confronté
à un nombre considérable de maladies du
sang que nous pouvons soigner et même
mieux que nous vous pouvons guérir
toutes sortes d'anémie de leucémie de
cancer du sang toutes sortes d'affection
qui pose un tout petit problème dans la
discussion que j'aimerais avoir avec
vous c'est simplement que le
l'hématologiste que je suis gagne sa vie
à travers le
diagnostic des maladies du sang en
prenant en charge tous les patients donc
on est d'emblé dans une notion de
conflit d'intérêt entre la maladie la
santé le diagnostic et l'activité
médical et ceci est peut-être encore
plus rempli quand on va regarder au fil
des années où se situe où se passe le
sang il est présent dans la littérature
dans la philatélie au cinéma dans les
valeurs religieuses sur les étiquettes
de vin évidemment puisque il y a le sang
du Christ qui est qui existe comme vin
on l'a trouvé on a fait des dégustations
à ce propos mais le sang est vraiment
partout et ce sang qui est partout il a
été vendu vendu par les Suisses il y a
une toute petite armée qui reste qui se
trouve être au Vatican mais ici ça c'est
les Tuileries où les Suisses se sont
fait massacrer et le sang des Suisses a
été vendu depuis longtemps pour tenter
de diminuer les forces qui se trouvaient
à la campagne et que les fermiers
n'aient pas trop de bras pour se
révolter le point important et qui me
choque maintenant même si Victor Hugo
l'a bien décrit dans Les Misérables
quand on voit Fantine qui va être obligé
pour faire vivre sa fille Cosette
de vendre ses cheveux ses dents son
corps mais maintenant ce que vous
trouvez sur Internet c'est des choses
absolument horribles qui vont dépasser
le commerce sanguin c'est le commerce
des organes vous voyez ici Rin à vendre
en haut à droite toute partie du corps
peut-être vendue et ce cannibalisme
médical moderne nous pose des questions
il nous pose aussi des questions par
rapport au produits sanguin et pourquoi
je me permets de dire ça c'est parce que
nous
vendons le sang est-ce vrai et on peut
se questionner non en fait on peut être
jésuite dans la réponse mais il faut pas
confondre valeur et
prix l'objet qui est le sang ce don qui
est fait n'est pas vendu ce qui est
vendu ce qui est commercialisé ce qui va
avec ce sont les plastiques ce sont les
analyses ce sont l'électricité ce sont
les salaires des collaborateurs mais le
sang reste une valeur absolument pure
que personne ne pourrait s'offrir
au-delà là d'une éthique du don et c'est
la raison pour laquelle quand je vois
toutes ces poches cette approche
industrielle et cette perversion quelque
part que le législateur a voulu dans
notre pays puisque dès le moment où la
première goutte de sang quitte votre
veine elle devient matière première
elle devient matière première et le don
qui est fait disparaît c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'aimerais qu'on puisse
étiqueter ces poches en mettant une
petite valeur supplémentaire c'est
provient d'un donneur bénévole et non
rémunéré ce serait chouette si on avait
ça tout au long de la chaîne
transfusionnelle je sais pas si je le
verrais de mon vivant bon je sais pas
encore combien d'années je vais vivre
ceci dit dans le canton de veau on
utilise et les besoins c'est 100 dons
200 par jour ouvra et c'est une somme
relativement importante puisque'en
Europe les besoins en produit sanguins
c'est de l'ordre de 60 concentré ritrocè
donc poche de de globule rouge pour 1000
habitants c'est en Allemagne en France
on est plutôt autour des 30 et dans le
canton de vaau on est au milieu il y en
a point comme nous on est plutôt à 40
unité de sang pour 1000 habitants ça
veut dire 45 l de sang 20 l de globules
rouge 7 kg d'hémoglobine 1 kg
d'anticorps 2.7 Kg d'albumine 20 g de
fer qui sont collectés chez nos
concitoyens tous les jours c'est des
sommes
considérables et puis une des valeurs
fondamentales de ce produit qui est le
sang c'est l'expression de l'altruisme
j'ai bien cette image du petit journal
où le médecin donne le sang à sa
patiente mais ce lien entre le donneur
et le receveur est l'expression de
l'altruisme de notre société
l'expression même de la capacité que
l'individu à être inséré dans la société
et la société autour de
l'individu mais finalement quand on
regarde attentivement le globule rouge
le globule rouge est un élément
essentiel de la vie il contient du fer
la plupart des planètes que vous voyez
défiler ici ont un cœur qui est centré
concentré constitué du fer qui résulte
de la fission et de la fusion nucléaire
j'ai envie de dire qu'à travers le
globule rouge nous respirons l'univers
alors si vous avez un petit peu de temps
et si vous êtes capable
donnez-le